what's happening there reject nation we are going
to watch today the first trailer for obi-wan hello
there but before we go into that i want to
say a special thank you to a sponsor we have
loved working with this past month and that is the
diss plate sometimes i just stand back there and
admire that poster for you art lovers out there
diss plate makes gorgeous prints on durable metal
sheets that are super easy to install display
and swap out and they've over a million designs
in their stores ranging from independent
artists to some of our favorite ips like
star wars dc and marvel and you won't need any
power tools to install them thanks to displaced
magnet based mounting system takes all of about 20
seconds to install we also got spidey on the wall
here and since john's a big horror fan we also
got this awesome trick-or-treat display which will
not be hung here we don't do that elsewhere disc
plate plants a tree for each one you buy and they
ship to 56 countries worldwide so hit our special
link in the description box and save yourself 23
on your first one or two displays
or save 27 when you grab three or
more support stem supports the channel
supports you and seems like you're not
living in some like blank colorless
void in your life now on to the video
the fight is done
we lost kenobi of arabia
rookie
oh they're compassionate oh damn
uncle owen
the jedi code is like an itch
oh my goodness this looks great
holy bolts ah the lightsaber on
the eye it's good it's a good touch
nice comes out when a new hope was originally
released in 1937 we got to travel back in order
to see it that's good marketing that looks great
that looks really so it seems like that vader
dispatched the inquisitors to go find obi-wan
specifically yeah he's bitter unless there's a
mislead here with the trailer we're gonna like
no i think my son's out there don't let him get
away go kill that kid that looked awesome that
looked like a movie absolutely like a move was
but yeah this looks more vital and more lived
in after they start playing duel of the fates
that was beautiful absolutely beautiful to bring
it full circle with the first appearance from
obi-wan kenobi's even mcgregor and then now to
have his show a series that we've been wanting
for so long imported chapter in his life now we
got the inquisitor showing up here first time in
live action if i'm not mistaken so if you guys
watch rebels or played star wars jedi fallen
order you will be familiar with the inquisitors
obviously they are like people who are dispatched
to hunt down jedi who survived after order 66 or
hunt down force sensitive children i remember even
playing a jedi fallen order i think it was the
second sister yes i forgot her actual name took me
like four hours to beat her i had to stop
playing it and then continue the next day
did it in 30 minutes there you go that's the plot
leak for how this is going to end when he fights
this show in 30 minutes i'm going to take a break
we'll come back tomorrow i'm gonna beat you then
fresh eyes and then with the grand inquisitor uh
he is hailed as like just right behind darth vader
in terms of like most powerful you know he's
he's extremely powerful i would recommend just
going to watch rebels i won't talk spoilers
about it but it's exciting to have him here
there's a really big threat in rebels he's
badass to behold jason isaac's voiced them
in the animated series now to see him brought to
live action is just so neat and they even got the
specific types of unique lightsabers the spinning
ones oh yeah that looked cool and then so here
it looks like the main villain tasked to hunting
down uh it looks like at least the trailer saying
the one to hunt down obi-wan is gonna be reba i
thought she'd have a helmet or something i always
associate them with having helmets you do see them
in their quarters at one point where it looks like
you're gonna see some of the other inquisitors as
well who we've seen in rebels more importantly i
mean just what this looks like it's just it looks
like cinematic as [ __ ] like it looks beautiful i
like seeing like the the little bits of obi-wan
that we got like when he's watching luke at the
beginning who's like i'm going to be a pilot one
day ah and then obi-wan's look at him like i've
seen this before yes yes i remember being here
tattooing second one kid racing he's just like his
pups also with the sort of um despairing portrayal
that we have here of uncle owen with joel edgerton
reprising his role i imagine that this will also
explore what ultimately led to them having this
like tension between them because as we saw in
a new hope the way how uncle owen describes him
he calls him like a crazy old wizard you know
when you actually catch up with obi-wan in that
film when luke brings up the name obi-wan
kenobi obi-wan responds in a way like i
haven't heard that name oh my god i forgot all
about him so i think we're going to be seeing
you know a this transition from obi-wan just fully
succumbing to becoming ben kenobi where he has you
know lost so much sight of his former self maybe
perhaps i don't know it's a very specific chapter
we'll also see what led to uncle owen completely
mistrusting or wanting nothing to do with obi-wan
like i i think what will happen is through these
series of events uncle owen would ultimately
find obi-wan's presence to be a threat to luke's
safety yeah with everything that he brings with
him and i'm curious to see how that played that
because i mean hearing the description that we're
gonna join obi-wan in a state where he is more
disparate and he is more faithless i believe as
the press brief uh puts it that hearkens to me to
the idea that they went with for luke in the last
jedi which i can't imagine they'll do here so
i'm curious to see how they change that flavor
because also i mean evan mcgregor is one of the
best actors to grace a star wars movie uh because
you know i mean sometimes the acting isn't always
the best or the most you know enlivened and i feel
like he has the perfect blend for this world where
he can fit perfectly in with like the elements of
the star wars acting flavor that you associate but
also really bring that pathos and that gravitas
and whatnot like to see this middle chapter i'm
curious to know how they will you know embolden
the stakes because we know that luke little luke
is not going to fall into the wrong hands probably
at least not for long if he does that's the big
question mark for me now is how are they going
to make this middle chapter vital and i hope they
do that via you know a strong character study of
this you know titular character who's supposed to
have a movie focused on him and now a show i feel
like is even better because you can dig into all
those layers and bring in all your cool other star
wars you know uh inquisitor characters and whatnot
well it's reported to be six episodes and each one
is going to be at least an hour long that's
what was reported it looked like at one point
here that they would go off tattooing at some
point or maybe it isn't tattooing i'm not sure
they've hyped up a place called daiyu which
is supposed to have like yeah like a criminal
nightlife and it's supposed to be very neon washed
and edgy it's like major poor exactly like madrid
star wars drappor i think deborah chao said it was
like a a city out of hong kong based off hong kong
yeah i think this looks awesome deborah chow the
work that she's done in star wars already has been
phenomenal i can't wait to see this show you
best bet we're going to be doing reactions to
it guys what'd you think about the obi-wan
trailer leave your thoughts down below
subscribe click the notification bell major things
to display for sponsoring this video helps get
around that duel of the fates copyright
claim but before we leave let's do a pic
we're gonna keep this straight to the point
michael b go michael b if if we're gonna be
covering this show you can bet michael b is gonna
be covering this show so michael hey prep yourself
the star wars fans are coming and if you're a
star wars fan has made to this point in the video
go subscribe to omni media and keep an eye out
for his reactions just make sure that you watch
them after you watch our reactions because we
sense you that's the hierarchy of things michael
b he's got great insights he knows the world he
is an expert and a nerd on the highest level of
the highest order we love him and uh hey buddy
we'll catch you soon thanks for being here yeah
you